[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate okay but the purple is a
satives and you're gonna want to do that
to be chats purple sativa so sativa's
the one that's a little bit more energy
yes okay so i'm gonna take about take a
five milligrams sativia stevia yes
take it and then you're gonna take it
yeah i'll take one sure you take one
chris and eddie show's gonna start about
15 minutes i'm gonna let it kick in all
right there it is babe are these are
like uh how delicious were they amazing
are they under the denver denver oh this
is all in the oven right and what was
the dose
it was five okay but to be honest with
you i'm gonna smoke a little as well
okay good good you know what because i
want to give you guys an experience so
am i
oh and we got brown sugar pie oh
i was gonna clean my room until i had
[Applause]
because
wow this is great this is uh we're doing
the chris and eddie show woo
and salvocano is my guess my bff for
life i took an edible five millis i'm
[ __ ] smacked a million million
million
million i i mean brown sugar pie from um
from uh the pearl in columbus ohio
brown
no that's not brown sugar
and i know that a little day
you know what's inside
hey
brown sugar
like japan i i didn't even think you
were going to take a guess that good for
you
it's the stones the stones this i i also
took that i also smoked a little bit and
i'll tell you right now you're feeling
it i was about to sing
uh
wild horses i was about to go brown
sugar
and i'm like that's not the song wild
horses is another stone song
brown sugar is better than white sugar
so this is not that unhealthy
that's actually true right brown sugar
is why it's not refined brown sugar
ain't refined now chris has been going
to the gym everybody but he's also been
running through some apps no well who's
running through apps
oh god all right
you ready for this do you mind if i have
a lozenge
will that will that will that be
annoying if i have
every morning
every morning on this tour
i've walked in the morning when i wake
up there's a bing bomb on my
girlfriend's foot
i know she loves me and she knows that i
can do
something that's eating goddamnit
shut the door baby what is it baby
sugar ray who hosts on sirius xm now i
use it every morning they're not just
every morning babes i've been going to
the gym i've been trying to run two
miles i've been doing 200 push-ups 200
pushes 200 cities
and also trying to lift weights and
every single morning i've gone to the
gym at seven a.m and every single
morning homeless pimp has been there an
hour before me
he's a beast a man's a beast homeless
pam he's not a man at eclipse he is a
machine homeless we've been on the road
with homeless pimp for the last six days
and i'm i'm as god as my witness
in six days he's eaten three strips of
grilled chicken and drank 49 beers
and he's taken one shower folks yeah and
because i stay in the room with him and
it's just
it's a sight to be seen but babe we've
been having he consumes lettuce like a
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] like
he's a rabbit dude yeah literally
homeless pimp is the homeless rabbit cat
one time i was sent to the store to buy
lettuce and i
bought cabbage can you tell the
difference between lettuce and cabbage
yeah in in the raw state like in the
isle supermarket island
they look similar to me
yeah what's lettuce in spanish
lachugh lachuga
lechuga you think you are
cabbage and lettuce are both green
vegetables that have many layers of
leaves however cabbage is tougher and
contains less water than lettuce does
cabbage is typically boiled or steamed
or used in cold slaw lettuce is known
for being crunchy which is why is it
used in salads or on burgers i'll tell
you right now
cabbage outside of a slaw
is just not good we shouldn't be eating
it i feel like it should be one of those
greens that we aren't supposed to eat i
would say in my life clover if i had to
be honest with you right now in my
entire 37 years of living i've eaten
coleslaw maybe three times
i ordered it today you turned it down i
turned it down i ate all the cornbread i
had all the mac and cheese i ate the
[ __ ] pickles but i don't i'm not
chrissy coleslaw yeah you know um why is
that
because i just it doesn't speak to me
are you are you not a mayo person as
well no i love mayo i'm looking right
into the jar shout out hellman's okay
shout out helmets i um i um and not a
huge mayo fan but if it's sparse and
it's done right in the coleslaw i enjoy
it but there's also slaw without mayo
that's really gangbusters outside of
that though the cabbage is a hot [ __ ]
can we get a gangbusters count pimp
that's the first gangbust time to say
gangbusters can we get a gangbusters cow
for the episode thank you
in its origins and it can be traced back
as far as the ancient romans my friends
served a dish of cabbage vinegar eggs
and spices the dutch who found in new
york state grew cabbage around the
hudson river that they used in a
shredded cabbage salad they called kusla
cool means cabbage and slaw is salad oh
wow cool that means cabbage someone said
you're cool we're really saying you're
cabbage coolslaw coolslaw
kusala no kusla kusla
what kind of weed was that
because that edible i tasted the weed in
the in the edible but but right but it
wasn't gross right and then also the the
uh the tart the fruitness of it was
really really powerful it was honestly i
could have eaten two or three of them
and i've had like vodka sodas yeah so i
am what we call
some act
now now that's from hip is getting
skinnier as the show goes on
it's like the movie thinner
by the end of it he's gonna look like
[ __ ] pants dj
pimp i've said it a million times but
the sunflower pants look like the
coronavirus and i want to vaccinate your
pants
can i put little masks all over the
sunflowers
do it
but uh sal i did want to ask you because
we're on the eddie show what was your
worst high
oh i've had many nobody's there one
that's there's one where it's like
you're just too paranoid you're just
freaking out yeah yeah there was two two
where i was like literally being like i
like almost like crying being like i
would i would like this to end when is
this gonna end well can you can you give
us background yeah yeah once i was at my
house one time my girlfriend does i uh
one time um when edibles were the wild
west now they're regulated they're okay
you know obviously and that edible is
from denver that's some good stuff
unbelievable
how did it travel legally here did it
travel in your anal cavity absolutely
illegally nice
nice and a sal salvocano anal cavity
edible is what i ate five mils
um
so you know one time my friend he's a
great guy he took drugs
we used to go to the
these clubs in the city like
i mean i can't believe i went to these
places but like tunnel sound factory all
that stuff and my friend one time he had
drugs on him inside the club and i said
how the hell did you get by because it's
so strict so strict
and he said he had it in a baggie in his
ass crack
interesting yeah interesting and i
really
to this day that has really bugged me
out my aunt eileen shout out my aunt
eileen worked at wyckoff heights
hospital for many many years told me
told the family that many many people
would come in because she was a
hematologist many many she would have to
get their blood or whatever many many
people like
multiple men a day a shift like could
guarantee at least five would come in
with some type of uh object in their ass
cavity
daily every single day in the 90s and
early 2000s in brooklyn new york married
men hasidic jewish men everybody was
coming in with something in their ass so
it's a very common thing to put things
up your butt yeah i've never done it
besides a finger i will be honest with
you i've never done an anal with a woman
i've never had anal received but very
very often i do stick i would say
half of my finger up to my knuckle with
the washcloth in my [ __ ] oh wow
there's been a couple of times where
uh it's been painful but i do it anyway
because i i just i'm very
serious about having a squeaky clean
[ __ ]
what are you doing with that i'm really
speechless i love that he said
almost daily he goes up to his knuckle
in his muscle with a washcloth it's one
of those just makes it even girthier and
rough and your and your entire take on
it was wow
i can't believe how you accepted that
that's why i always saw it i imploded
that's why i always religiously every
single time i stay in a hotel every
hotel we've stayed in i give a 25 tip to
the housekeepers because they are
cleaning up [ __ ] washcloths
you don't get
stuff on it wait a minute it depends how
deep we go so
um
why would you go up that far because
inside there i think is its own thing
that doesn't need to be soaked because
there's a there's a part of it
there's a part of me that thinks every
day it doesn't matter what situation i'm
in every day i just feel like there's
there's a a time where someone could
have their nose in my [ __ ] and i just
wanted it to be a nice experience for
them so but it doesn't matter like i
can't remember where you're going i
could be at thanksgiving with my mom i'm
thinking listen there's a chance a
police officer come in and say we need
to solve a crime the only way to do that
is to smell chrissy's ass crack and i
want it to smell like dove soap and and
a type of lotion and one of sal's
candles that he bought in columbus
it's very nice of you
very yeah you know
pimp let me ask you this let me ask you
this how have you first of all we're in
columbus ohio how do you feel about
columbus ohio so far because at first
you didn't like it the starbucks was
closed in the lobby so i'm and then the
importance was closed yeah everything
seems to be closed between two to five
in cities not on the coast
yeah right
wait where are we talking about again
columbus oh cause that happened in st
louis it happened a few times now yeah
it happened today you oh cause that's
why we picked you up like you have to
keep walking so you found it yeah but i
like a lot of uh thrift shops and you're
thrifty guy you're a thrift store guy
this is a true story we were walking on
north high street
okay today i mean you were with me not
okay i mean you were there yep yeah and
we were together and someone ran across
the street
calling us
and he had business cards in his hand oh
he said i was
300 feet away
and i noticed how pimp dressed yep and i
thought you might like to know we're a
vintage store across the street that
might that has his foot there yeah
that's what he said and who else who was
wearing something else was february 26
borgata atlantic city that's the
rescheduled date february 26th
march 4th royal oak michigan royal oak
music theater march 5th gramercy theater
new york city specially washi taping two
shows get there march 11th nashville
tennessee co-headlining with my babe sav
volcano march 18 seattle washington
march 19 portland oregon march 25th las
vegas nevada and april 8th indianapolis
april 9 denver colorado april 29
bethlehem pennsylvania
chrisdcomedy.com for tiki wikis march
5th the special gramercy theater be
there baby be part of it
what's up guys going to give you some
tour dates here albany and dc february
18th and february 19th still some
tickets left to that albany show there's
two shows uh madison and chicago
february 26 and february 27th i'll be at
the barrymore theater and the vic
nashville lacrista stefano playing the
ryman on march 11th the next day i'll be
in chattanooga on march 12th i'll
reschedule reschedule burlington to may
13th also rescheduled san diego in los
angeles i will be in san diego on may
25th in los angeles on may 22nd and then
the reschedule of foxwoods is june 25th
oh [ __ ]
hey everybody i'm at the beacon theater
and i will be playing here on may 14th
headlining doing stand-up tickets are on
sale right now at savillcanoecomedy.com
uh yeah just the building's beautiful
and i'm just touring it right now to see
the vibe but i'm thrilled um
and just come
you
see the thing is with that guy too shout
out that guy uh the columbus uh i
reposted him on my instagram i forgot
what the name of their event do you
remember what the name is it lux
textile something
it's it's on high street it's a brand
new place fantastic gear
he
he vaguely peripherally knew who saloni
was he couldn't quite pin it but by the
end of our session there i'm pretty
confident you know who you are he didn't
know who i was no
attack lux in columbus ohio shout out
taclex i'm almost positive by the time
we purchased items and left that store
he was convinced that i was andrew
schultz
and sal and sal was carson daly that's
what i think he thought
so
and he was confident that he was like yo
i just met those [ __ ] because i
because he said i can't wait to post you
two and i've yet to be tagged in any
post from that store so i'm i'm
completely convinced he tagged the wrong
people for the both of us well you did
put on quite the fashion show in that
new jacket i bought a new york giants
jacket i bought a new york giants jacket
that has to be from 1990 lawrence
taylor's put it on right now model it
you want me to go get it oh
it's not here it's not here i actually
was going to come onto stage tonight
with my new york giants jacket with the
lady gaga this is a new shirt yeah this
is a new lady gaga shirt and and as you
guys know as i've said many times on the
chrissy chaos podcast and maybe hey babe
i touched lady gaga's butt uh once in
2014 and she told me never to wash my
hand um and i still have not
love you shout out lady gaga and um
don't don't ever wash your hand but if
you can get knuckle deep in that [ __ ]
every day yes
yeah
knuckle deep in the [ __ ] is yeah
can i ever tell you i'll go ahead for a
second speaking of knuckle deep in the
[ __ ] did i ever tell you about the
time i went to derek jeter's 40th
birthday party with sway from sway in
the morning did i ever tell you this um
i vaguely remember it okay so random day
whenever derek cheetah's birthday is i
get a call from sway from sway in the
morning shout out shout out uh shout out
sway shout out kanye west shout out you
ain't got the answer swag
[Laughter]
i love that yeah you ain't got the
answer this way so you know what's great
really played that cool too so sway when
i was like like he was he was very that
was he looked very good in that when i
never forget i was co-hosting a show
with sway during that time it was called
off the bat it was on mtv 17 whatever
you know it was a show that went nowhere
but it was fun it was me swaying fat joe
and melanie iglesias so
when that happened you ain't got the
answer sway that morning he had to come
to set that day like at 11 a.m and he
already two hours after it happened was
on the phone with his business manager
being like yo we need we need you ain't
got the answer sway t-shirt's ready to
go immediately yeah immediately he knew
it was gonna go viral and he did and
he's he told me he made more money
with this with the
answer sway merch
you ain't got to answer sway tv i should
i sway the person in front of me can we
get him on the show i love him sway will
one thousand percent come on the show
he's he's i was supposed to be i would
the guys were on sway i couldn't make it
that day but i think they went on sway
did they sway interviewed tupac biggie
and barack obama nobody's got nobody's
done yeah yeah nobody's done that um
wow okay so let me just tell you real
quick so it was june of 2014. sway
called me up he's like do you want to go
to derek judah's birthday party i was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me no
perhaps yes oh yes
yeah i said i said who do you think i've
been jerking off to the last 14 years
yes
so
so we show up it's a pretty you know
awesome birthday party slim shady was
there slim shady's manager was there
where was this um
it was on for it was on um on uh i got
nightclubs it was on eight like in the
meatpacking district you know one of
those jobs one of those jobs it was like
maybe the whitney museum or something
like that they can rent it out something
like that yeah that space and um i do i
can't confirm they have functions there
their functions yeah so this is where
jeter's party was and all the yankees
were there posada bernie williams
everybody and then you know it's pretty
like whatever and then all of a sudden
they drop down two bird cages and two
you know uh dancers come out with derek
jeter jerseys on strip them off
immediately then our handed wiffle ball
bats lubed from top to bottom with
vaseline and proceed to shove as much of
the wiffle bat as they can into their
vagina and dance around and then they
said you guys ready for the birthday boy
and then derek jeter came out with a
diet pepsi and sat down and looked on
looked at his phone immediately and took
a look at the girls looping baseball
bats
i did not hear this i was in shock we
all had to any derek jeter function you
have to put your cell phone in a bowl
that they locked this was before the
bags yeah so nobody had you can't film
this but i saw multiple women dancing
around sway as my witness on god
sway base god that they were that yeah
this was the show they were lubing up
wiffle ball bats shoving their vaginas
dancing around saying give it up for the
birthday boy and derek jeter couldn't
[ __ ] care less
wow it was nice how is it that i don't
know this story how is that i swear to
god i left that party at about 1am and i
got dollar pizza and took the bus home
oh
wow he didn't even look up wait so he
was did he know what was going on with
the bats i don't know that he knew i
think it was probably put on by you know
somebody in the yankees organization i'm
wondering if he i'm wondering if he
didn't see that part
it came out or he knew that that was
going to happen because that is that's a
nice tribute that is very nice but that
is uh well but i think it's it's par for
the course with derek jeter's life right
i mean that is salacious no i'm not
lying to you
one of these girls i mean she almost got
to the [ __ ] like she got oh you put
the newspaper in she got 75 percent of
that wiffle bad upper vagina wow you're
getting to the skinny part 100
i was like holy [ __ ] honey i was like do
you even have organs
the yellow with a ball right not the one
that's not on super water no flintstones
yellow like what's cool about they used
to tape up with duct tape oh i thought
it was wood
oh my god
what are you a [ __ ] handler
jesus christ
run nazi camps i do have a couple of
talking about porn here the best news
articles from this last year best new
cause of best news articles of 2020 my
favorite
you ready all right hey listen
czech woman performs oral sex to stop
robbery of slovak gas station so this
woman got down and to stop a robbery
started giving oral
yeah so wow think about the guy or gal
whoever robbed that store well we don't
know if it's a guy or a girl right
i would assume it's a god i would i
would think it's a it's uh it's
[Music]
how great would it be if a woman was
robbing the store and that was just
that is a hundred times better because
that would never play out like that
because it's like if she got away if he
or she got away with the robbery it's
like who's having a better day than them
they got they robbed they robbed the gas
station walked away with money and got
head [ __ ] fantastic home run yeah i
don't know somebody's robbing you what
do you say if they go let's have sex and
i'll stop robbing you i would do it
immediately
if i if somebody put a gun to my head
and said i will remove this gun from
your head if you just get down on your
knees and blow me i would be at his
belly button before he even finished the
sentence i'd be in there yeah
what if he didn't he doesn't end up
saying what you thought he was gonna say
that's awkward then i'm gonna give him a
[ __ ] and he'll shoot me in the head
what are you gonna do that'll be my last
moment
wow i came out of the closet on my way
to heaven
but the guy that was robbing the gas
station right where's his head at like
you know what i'm saying he must not
have been all there
because
you don't
you can't stop for i mean you can't stop
for a [ __ ] after you've robbed the
gas station but i what my question would
do that but do you think that he
suggested or she said hey
how about i blow you right now and you
and you stop the robbery it depends on
what was in the till
right if you got 17 bucks from the
register you stop you take the yeah what
money is it gonna call you would you
guys give her a raise if you own the
place if i own the place i'd ask for a
blow job
no
i didn't take it as that she worked
there
just said also i would really i would
really love it if she was a random
that's more fun for me as well that's
great yeah she didn't even work there
she was just in the show yeah i don't i
took it as she was just a customer was
like oh my god what can i do to help
yeah interesting all right that's a good
story here's another one here's another
one dozens of camels barred from saudi
beauty contests over botox so so the
camels got botox yeah and they got
disqualified because it was like
steroids
i mean have you ever seen a camel's lips
maybe you don't need botox no camel's
got them thick lips yeah look at a
camel's lips google camel's lips and
tell me if you don't get a little chub
but that's in that's look at those come
on baby look at that lower lip that just
shows you where we are as decided now
that even those lips aren't big enough
for us yeah
i mean look at that i mean if we're
getting the botox there that's more
scary to me than govind look at that
that's that's where we are as a society
that's what we value a lot of women
i'd love to go to a camel beauty contest
that's another thing well i guess we
have the dog
contests right yeah listen like dogs
deserve using the eye of the beholder
um all right what's the next story
taking viagra cuts the risk of
alzheimer's by up to 69
i read that alzheimer's viagra i didn't
know that but alcoholism
prevents alzheimer's if you're an
alcoholic they're very very low rate of
alzheimer's so if you want to prevent
alzheimer's start drinking how many
people do you think that you just turned
into an alcoholic i hope most percentage
of your listeners i would have a percent
i would say 60 i would say 75
i just turned 75 into alcoholics
yeah because because the
oh i think it's one of the worst things
you could happen you get your life
robbed from you you get your memory
yep i mean come on yes that's all
anything is worse is when you have you
when you're at the end of your life it's
all it's worth that's all that means
anything and you get it taken prior to
that but you get it i should get into
that age it's so [ __ ] depressing but
when you die and the simulation ends and
you go back to your body on another
planet because this is all video game
you probably get the memories back knock
on glass
it's the most interesting illness though
they're kind of like purgatory on earth
oh god
you don't want that you don't wha what's
your biggest fear sal my heart goes out
why to die to die of what's the biggest
fear to die of oh i don't know man dying
i don't know dying every way
anyway i i'm so scared of death well let
me
put you i'm going to talk about it in
therapy
alzheimer's better huh would you would
you rather die of alzheimer's be eaten
by an animal or fall off a building
would i rather you're going to die one
of three ways alzheimer's
eaten by an animal fall off a building
which one would you go with i mean it
probably also was at that point you
wouldn't want to fall in the building
it's over 1-2-3
but
then they say you die before you hit the
ground that's what they say
how's that possible because they say you
have a heart attack from the fear but
how would they know they can't into it
what if you don't what if i was a base
jumper
but i think that they have a they they
have a parachute
if you jump off they say before you hit
the water or the ground that you have a
heart attack that's what that's what um
that's what uh
somebody said that sylvia brown psychic
[Music]
miss cleo miss cleo said that you know i
have the same lawyer as [ __ ] the long
island medium that's how i know i got to
change lawyers
really
sometimes my lawyer won't pick up my
call because he's busy with the [ __ ]
long island milk medium teresa caputo
i'm like i'm getting sued by warner
media pick up the [ __ ] phone
i actually know her daughter was a very
nice young lady who her daughter long
i'll meet him no shout outs only i mean
i [ __ ] love the lawyer i meet him she
has to check how i am
well i am loyal i mean oh yeah no i love
teresa caputo but it's just funny that
it's funny that you know i mean well she
makes a ton more money than me i
actually i don't know if i've i've seen
eclipse but i don't know if i've ever
watched like an extended amount of it
long island mediums does she always read
people's she's [ __ ] every show 100
wow and she nails it dude yeah nails it
in sick beehive hair yeah i love teresa
caputo how about this italian hospital
employee accused of skipping work for 15
years
for 15 years he never showed up for a
day of work apparently and he got away
with it honestly if i was an italian
taxpayer i would give him the money for
that it's like i know dude that's all
he's better than you he's better better
than you i uh one time in college there
was a couple classes here and there that
i
i just went to like i also have a
technique in college uh i would wait
till the last day that you were allowed
to transfer classes before i even went
to school
wow and then on the last day that you
were allowed to i would just like walk
into each class like stumbling with my
paperwork crumpled and be like i i i
supposed to come here i transferred
so i wouldn't go the first two weeks and
that wouldn't that was no big deal and
then i would find a way anytime they
that the teacher you had to sign in that
you were there i had someone sign for me
and there were times that there were
classes that were really terrible only
they were terrible right that i went to
like to check in the first day and then
for the midterm and the final i was
there three times
in the four months or of the five months
of the semester but you passed the class
yes wow yeah
i mean it yeah college i failed one
class in all of college for the four
years i still graduate on time but that
happened to also be one of the ones i
did what'd you fail
i took the pass fail option do you
remember that sure so you would get like
one of them as a year or something like
that and you could either choose to pass
it a fail yeah like it's no grade yeah
no grade just i don't get any you know i
get the credit but i don't get like
anything
i took the pass fail option and the
[ __ ] still failed me what class
was that it was uh
jesus christ
i don't know you don't remember i can't
remember the name of the class what was
your name it was like very weird like
business statistics statistics uh oh
statistics suck yeah whatever it was
what the [ __ ] was it
anyway
yeah and and one time it was like a
night class too this one i took it a few
times but uh and
and we would just sit there and be
freaking nine o'clock at night on a
wednesday and this guy is doing these
computations and permutations that are
just going across the whole board that's
like we're not even in advanced like
yeah it's too much and i raised my hand
i was like because because one time he
said we're going to do a calculation to
determine it's like engineering
uh we're going to determine
the strength of a piece of tinsel
and it was a three-hour math problem and
i just raised my hand i raised my hand
genuinely i raised my hand and i said
what would i ever use this for yeah you
know how would i apply this i i don't
understand how i would apply this
and i think he was like i don't know
what he said
uh but
then there was a kid behind me that was
a real dick it sounds like i'm a dick
but this guy didn't have a good rep
you're not a dude and he said he goes
dude enough you if you don't know where
you can apply this
like you said you think about it he was
mad because yeah because you stopped he
was mad because i asked like how would i
would use this he thought it was like i
don't know he's like he's like i he uses
he needs to know the density of tinsel
yeah he's got he's [ __ ] christmas
he's an elf
i don't even know how he got on this i
don't even know what tinsel is what is
tinsel what do they call a tinsel town
it's like garland because it's shiny and
shimmery i don't know
right tinsel is that little like like
you ever see the trees from like the 70s
and 80s of christmas trees it's not just
the rope of garland it's like when they
it's almost like
you know the fake
hay
in easter baskets yes those cellophane
strips yes yeah so what were we talking
about again
um
we were talking about tinsel tinsel's
like that but shiny
it's you know and then they dr drip it
all over the tree like
you look like a guy whose
tinsel is right up your alley you know i
loved tinsel i used to love tinsel back
in the day because my grandparents used
it right they they were the last of the
people i knew that used it so i have a
little bit of an affinity to it you're a
guy if it looks like [ __ ] if i didn't
know who you are if i had no idea what's
going on
and you were homeless pimp's friend and
he introduced me to you and he said what
do you think my friend does i'd say he's
a poet
you look like a poet with the glasses
with the hair you have a poetry look
right like if you were if you would if
you would say hey
draw a haiku i would draw a sal
[Laughter]
tinsel is actually banned in the u.s
tinsel is banned in the u.s at one point
wow so sal had a point south what the
[ __ ] this is illegal activity they would
contain lead until 72 as you can see in
a newspaper article from 1972 thanks
unnecessary risks to children with
symptoms of lead poisoning wow lead was
in everything back then
everything you you if you were born
before in 1980 you had blood poisoning
yeah pretty much right do you remember
when it was you got lead poisoning then
17. i probably have it yeah do you
remember when we were younger if you do
uh well you're a lot younger but they
were still eight nine years yeah yeah i
know but for tv like for the tv
it was so bad um
the lead poisoning that they used to
have the commercial you know how now
they say like if you have mesothelioma
right lead poisoning was like the one
they played all the time yes like suit
they were like if you have lead
poisoning yeah you used to come on all
day long when i watched my soaps and
game shows yeah well what about what
about when i was a kid every night i
would say randomly as soon as it hit 10
o'clock i said it's 10 o'clock do you
know where your children are now they
don't even attempt to do that anymore
they're like you know you don't want
your children are you [ __ ] freaks
yeah your children are in the metaverse
yeah that's what it is your ten-year-old
son is jerking off to an anime there's
no curfew in the metaverse yeah
all right listen if you're carrying a
credit balance month after month it can
feel like you're in a never-ending cycle
of debt with no end in sight upstart can
help you make that final payment so you
can get ahead listen rather than looking
at credit scores alone rather rather
than looking at uh credit score alone
upstart considers other factors like
your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in minutes for loans between 1 000 to 50
000 find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
providing your loan application
upstart.com
i mean this is the one
where are you going if you want 16 free
meals and three free gifts i will say
you could go to one place and one place
only that's america's number one meal
warm yourself up from the inside out
with limited time recipes inspired by
cozy classics from around the world like
beef tenderloin and cheese fondue or
miso sesame shrimp and bacon ramen
right to your door you don't have to go
out it's cheaper than the supermarket
they have you could prepare a meal
hellofresh cuts back on time spent in
the kitchen with prep at around 30
minutes or less plus quick and easy 20
minute recipes 72 percent cheaper than a
restaurant and now there's also hello
fresh customer right hello custom is
that true well you could choose if you
want extra protein or extra veg you
could actually choose what you want in
it and they'll like they'll make it
custom
your needs all you need to do even if
you're not sold on this idea what do you
have to lose go to
hellofresh.com16 and use code hey babe16
you're going to get 16 free meals and
three free gifts so i'm so confident
you're going to continue going along
with hellofresh because the food is so
amazing and you cook in 30 minutes or
less but literally why not just get 16
free meals and three free gifts just
because can't go wrong it's also cheaper
than the supermarket so the next time
you go to the supermarket be like let's
just try hellofresh for this round yeah
get your three free gifts she's 16 free
meals see if it's for you if it's for
you you might have started yourself on a
whole new journey hellofresh.com slash
hey babe 16 use the code hey babe 16 16
free meals and three free gifts what are
my four favorite words
america's number one meal kid
yeah kids don't go out anymore like that
i'm really hoping and praying both my
daughters are like huge fat lesbians
that would be so helpful take me through
it
because
i feel like if they because i i the fear
that i have as a father of them is if
they are beautiful grow up to be
beautiful girls like like their mother
is then you know they're gonna go out
they could get in trouble you know guys
whatever but if they're really i mean
fat lesbians then i feel like as long as
they could have a sense of joy it's
something and we can work on them and
being being happy and being who they are
typically lesbian relationship not too
much domestic violence everything's okay
and then when you're really really heavy
like that you know
i don't have to worry as a father so
much that you know these guys are over
here gonna [ __ ] do something harmful
to my daughter you know i wanted to be
fat and gay but healthy and happy
okay that's what i'm saying it's really
coming from a protective point of view
from a protective point of view i want
it happy first
i will say this happy first fat sec
happy first gay second fat third
so you'd rather they be fat than gay if
you had to choose between the two if i
if you gave me the perfect option yeah
if jesus came down and said what do you
want your kids to look like at 18 i
would say
john candy with wigs on gay as can be
that's what i wanted
yeah okay so yeah so really you we
really are defining them as maybe ugly
ugly is subjective ugly subjective
just
the fear that i have is my daughters are
going to grow up to be very very
beautiful women right and i'm going to
have to sit up all night because i'm not
going to be the dad that's like oh
[ __ ] i got a shotgun you know the
dad's like i got a [ __ ] shotgun it's
like shut up i don't have a shotgun i'm
not gonna i'm never gonna kill anybody
you know what i can't wait for when
that's the new vlog we're filming
waiting up for delilah oh my god we're
still hanging on to the [ __ ]
christmas character
yeah through ten years yeah he becomes
what he did not say he would sound like
a training order for me 10 years ago i'm
still hanging on we were saying like
this is just babe we lost the hay
self-fulfilling prophecy
we were saying the other day that at one
point everyone's grandfather's just
gonna have a podcast it's crazy
yeah i was i'm i can't believe that like
the the old old like white-haired people
will like gangsta rap it's true no it's
true it's gonna be such a weird thing
something like we've never witnessed
something no old grandpa's gonna have
podcasts and all grandmas are gonna have
like 10 like tattoos on their thighs
like paw prints on their thighs just
saggy skin oh the face tattoos are going
to face
what does takashi 6'9 gonna look like
when he's 87. wow it's gonna be sick
dude yeah
should we get chris johnson on yeah why
not let's bring on chris johnson he's
been with us the whole time now i'm
gonna tell before we come on chris what
i'm gonna tell you about chris is and
then wait until he gets to frame if you
don't know who he is chris johnson huge
wu tang fan grew up in foster care did
graffiti loves rap now check out what he
looks like
surprise surprise
[Laughter]
surprise surprise
counting in stock tips also
that is a white woman
folks almost clear you like sheamus
actually from wwe you know
where to go i was at a panera once and a
kid came up to me and he was like and
his mom was like he thinks you're
shameless can you take a picture with
him yeah yeah and i took a picture with
him and he how long have i known you now
it's got to be what is it like almost 10
years 10 years
right this moment is the first time i
ever noticed off saw you like i had
sheamus similar yeah yeah people this is
the first time sal's looked at you in
two years
music goes like this where's that
[ __ ] guy it just blew me away i mean
i've i can't believe i've never even
seen that before yeah he does i could
see it too
yeah i gotta go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ]
body type's a little different
but listen from the chin up that's
shameless double chin up yeah i look
like almost like him chris johnson baby
look at his red hair chris j comedy
folks i'm christy comey that's chris j
comedy yeah people years ago used to tag
me chris chris chris j comedy we'll be
at this comedy club and i'm like i'm not
there oh christy you'll be i'll take
those [ __ ] likes though yeah i'll
take them i'll take them take them baby
both of them well yeah man the fbi's
investigating us for domestic terrorism
um no but so chris comes on tour with us
chris comes on tour with us he [ __ ]
he just crushes it all day every day
i've i've enjoyed getting to know chris
um
uh he's been driving around as i said
he's got two double stuns our cubic
zarconium earrings but
family intact
which is usually you don't see that what
do you see cubicles zirconia the qvc
these are actually
they have carcinoma right what did i say
what's the hearing
i said he's got two cubic zirconiums
okay yeah did i say it wrong well i
think it's arconius yeah there's no m is
it not zirconium sounds like this
because i genuinely element but
well that's what i thought it was cubic
zirconium because i thought it was one
of like the elements maybe
is zirconium an element no it sounds
like something the marvel universe does
right right iron man would use zacchaeus
to make a fictitious shield yeah but
those are those cubics are cones those
are real no these are this i actually
had
i actually had bigger earrings
i got her smaller ones for christmas it
got even worse
she got even more divorced
as a punishment the guys make me wear
those
she shook me down for the bigger ones i
had to settle for these i swear wow
those aren't those are fine sizes for me
what i would say is truthfully i think
chris pulls off
for for for a 42 year old white man with
an entire family he pulls off two
earrings very well yeah
the crocs the two earrings and the the
half a mustache on my finger rocks two
earrings and yeah and it i think i think
you pull it off extremely well i love it
i mean me and chris were talking about
how your bladder held us up on the road
yes yeah i mean
i'm a pr yeah you pee so much it's
embarrassing and it's crazy this stuff
it's crazy because how much salon i
balance because i pee more than anyone
you've ever met upwards of 20 times a
day sound peace
fewer than any times you ever met he
said he pees once every two days so
together we have a normal bladder
combined it's like voltron and you do
have one normal bladder together most is
like once a day
how
once
a
have you pissed tonight it's it's it's
eleven o'clock at night we've been up
since seven o'clock in the morning
truthfully how many times have you
urinated truthfully i know um i urinated
uh when we got to the hotel
and then
i made myself try to urinate while you
were on stage and i was going to go out
because i didn't because i drank two
full waters bottles and i was like i
don't want to have to pee in the middle
of the set so i tried to urinate on
perps because i drank the two did you
get any out it was it was not that much
it was probably like i would probably
got it one and a half times i wouldn't i
don't know he got out at rest stops on
the road and sal just kind of kicked
back and and put his and i'm like you
need to go and he went he went it's not
my dad
everyone everyone in the van uh would go
and every time you go to me you're not
gonna go and i would just like nah i'm
all right i'd be like yeah but we have
another four hours i'm like no i'm good
we've talked about this on hay bay we've
reached out to doctors at the live shows
they've all said it's normal whatever
your normal is that's your normal
well
really no because i don't remember that
what did you do that makes you feel
better
i've many times said my name is sam
valcano and went into the doctor and
said these are my ailments just so i can
get info
but jesse you're a doctor too and
somebody should you say i don't think we
can fly dude i am not a doctor man i oh
i so want you to just please he brought
me up to stage that his doctor
i brought him those doctors
i want the plates and you you could
legally right use the suffix dr dot i
think you should walk around the lab
code 24 7. like
chris
the title is is all right fine
technically it's dr christopher
decephano comma dpt which is doctor of
physical therapy it's like i was making
fun of the podiatrist at the show
tonight he's a he's doctor of podiatry
so it's like yes he's a doctor but it's
like you do feet he's got mad at you he
got me he actually really i was [ __ ]
on a podiatrist in the front row saying
he's not a real doctor he's a really
good man he seemed a little kind of
stopped laughing and then you guys
brought up uh
the sign language interpreters oh the
son dude bringing up the sign language
if you're a sign language interpreter
please come to any of the live shows we
do because you will be part of the show
quick we didn't bring anybody up on
stage on all the previous shows because
we were scared about covid but that sign
language interpreter she got right in
our faces
and we loved i mean we were hugging them
i didn't even think of that you said
though he was like you see him signing
looks like they got little masks on
their fingers a little mess on their
face i know my sign language interpret
was kind of hot
um takes seven years apparently to get
your
sign language i believe it is
a sign language i believe it because if
you ever like actually focus on them i'm
fascinated with them and if you ever
focus it is intense it seems very hard
intense and if you guys you want to
learn how to do sign language go to
babble.com promo code hey babe yes
one of the 14 languages is signed
did you see this happen in new york
shut down
shuts down an h m shuts down nyc store
after employing leaks pick of bugs on
hoodies
oh man
that's not good are the bugs coming out
of the hoodies
i think it was probably just
i work at the h m and the oculus at the
world trade and today customer
discovered lice on a rack of hoodies
they're not closing the store nor are
they notifying employees of the problem
the section was just blocked off and
those lights aren't even wearing masks i
know that's horrible oh imagine having
lice in your hair
that sucks we know that listen if you've
had livestream here right at ryan at
patreon.com christy comedy right on the
community board and let us know about
your lice we'd love to see pictures of
it don't come looking near us but do you
remember when that one ran ran when we
were younger
in the school they had to check every
kid before they came in yeah and uh and
then maybe even again at the end of the
day they would do with the pencils and
with the yeah with the erasers on the
pencils yeah mine would do like like the
like the two pencils like chopsticks
nail filer things they would go through
the thing and and if you've got lice you
have to shave your head yes you would
use a barbara comb like a black barbacoa
like a
do they still do that now there's no way
they can even touch the kids anymore
they can't touch the kids
i mean it was on the reg when i was
younger no me too like you had no choice
it's like sister o'meara was gonna was
just gonna comb through your hair yeah
that's what it was gonna look for did
you have a violent nun because we had a
semi-violent nun yes i had a violent
nine and a violent brother oh i had a
yeah who was your violent non-existent
uh she uh she was like she could be nice
when she was nice she was older though
sister rachel shout out sister rachel
yeah and she was from just a registered
she's from italy
and uh but when but whenever she wanted
even if you weren't really over the top
if she was like in the mood maybe or i
don't know she used to grab you by your
ear real hard and pull it your kid
really kind of i had her in second grade
wow and she still pulled all the old
kids but she she would just yank it
where the kid would would always go
like you're actually hurting the kid
right and then she like
even it wasn't always like even if the
kid was out of his seat and she she also
like sometimes thought it was like not
funny but like like maybe she wasn't i
don't know anyway my point is one time
she grabbed the kids his soul he started
just bleeding all down his neck and
everything and like no no no no they
didn't give a [ __ ] literally no issue
they like white cleaned them up and that
was it there was no complaints from his
parents my i had a nun that would you if
you fell asleep in class
she would go to your desk
get two erasers fill them up with as
much chalk as she could
step on your foot so you start to wake
up and then hit you with erasers uh and
chalk would you breathe in chalk and
cough and that's insane that's insane
dude and that she was doing that until
the late 90s wow i had a teacher in
third grade uh i was talking to someone
and i guess she was tired of me talking
or when was we talking she threw the
eraser and i guess just a semi-fit of
rage from her desk she threw the eraser
probably thinking it was going to sail
over my head it hit me right in the [ __ ]
she threw it
was like a plume of smoke too was it
like i was talking about zest and i
wasn't looking at her i was talking so
it blindsided cracked
and i looked back at her and she saw her
life flash before her eyes because that
was over the top even then
i
i went down
and then i looked and my eye was just
pouring like
like because it was red and tearing and
i just i didn't even know what happened
and it like hurt it almost like someone
punched you a little bit and she just
was like oh my god i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry i i didn't mean to do that i'm so
sorry and i was just i don't remember
what happened but it was fine did you
tell your mom and dad i don't remember i
feel like you wouldn't tell your mom and
dad you would just take that with you so
my dad see i probably would have my dad
when he shut your dad nobody does more
shots of apple cider vinegar than sal's
dad
listening and we know that you are yeah
um he silva can't get that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
that's funny
he was having a full manchu on his
birthday wasn't he yeah
yeah um so so when he was young so when
he was younger i guess he's gotten even
pulling in the ears nothing because when
he was younger they used to hit you with
a ruler you said have you put your hands
down hit you with a ruler and one
uh
one nun they had it my dad had a metal
lunchbox and she hit him with a metal
lunchbox
like on his head uh she cracked him in
the head with the metal lunchbox
it was his lunchbox and he went home and
told my grandmother and my grandmother
went down to the school and literally
threatened the nun's life got right in
the face and cursed her out like don't
you and she he wasn't behaving he was
waving she was like i don't give a [ __ ]
he was you know like i think she really
like to the point where she's scared
than none in the school if if a nun
like today in 2021 2022 and hit a kid in
head with a metal box she would be
putting the electric she might be given
the death penalty yeah truthfully
on-site on-site yeah were you guys ever
spanked my dad was spanked by the
brothers
i never got spanked by the brothers
here we go
we're on the patreon folks it's okay
this might be headed out for haybay but
let it rip
i've been thinking about switching from
smoking
so and i there's only one real thing i'm
considering to make a switch from
smoking and that's lucy's nicotine
that's right nicotine alternative they
make gum they make lozenges they make
pouches for adults look people people
use negative adults here they use it to
relax they use it to focus or unwind i
get it there's nothing like that feeling
of just yeah just relax switching it out
i mean listen cigarettes are bad bro yes
listen now this product does contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical of course we know but if you
enjoy using nicotine you should just
definitely check out lucy's product at
lucy.co because it's just good it's just
like it's a better alternative to
smoking and if you go to lucy.co that's
lucy.co and use promo code babe b-a-b-e
that's promo code babe b-a-b-e you're
just gonna feel better about yourself
cha-ching shopify you know what it is
it's the sound cha-ching is the sound of
another sale on shopify yes that when i
make it when i go shhh that's because
you just made another sell on shopify
what is shopify our our listeners want
to know what is an all-in-one commerce
platform to start run and grow your
business
yeah and scaling your business is a
journey of endless possibility shopify
gives entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big businesses so upstarts
startups establish businesses alike can
sell everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
effortlessly stay informed when we put
our merch up for sale which is coming
very soon we're going to use shopify
believe me this podcast is is going to
start selling and and and when we start
selling we're going to we're going to
we're going to we're going to try a shop
before we're going to release the merch
it should be any day any day believe me
actually it might be out already
you know what it is you know this here's
what it is real quick as we talk about
shopify for us and for our specific
needs yeah uh because like like shopify
powers millions of businesses from first
sale to full scale and we are launching
an online store and we wanted to go live
with every product got it and some are
have because of cover there's
manufacturing delays and shipping so we
were like instead of launching with two
of three of the six things we'll wait a
little longer right but now we might
just put coming soon and launch with the
others and with shopify we can you can
launch as many products as you want
shopify is just amazing if you go to
shopify.com hey babe all lowercase for a
free 14-day trial and get full access to
shopify's entire suite of features so
grow your business with shopify today go
to shopify.com
hey babe right now that's shopify.com
hey babe for a free 14-day trial
i just had a bullet i told you guys you
had a bully i had a bull we had it we
all had a bully it was a
bb big black woman she was a bully yeah
yeah oh yeah you totally yeah
yeah oh really bad right really bad yeah
she was bigger than all of us she had
like her hair was done up and she had
glasses or sunglasses that was in her
hair it was part of like her hair she
was like the first guy she would just go
watch this all the time
she used to tell us she was a patchy
member i need a gangster [ __ ] that's
gangster she was her cousin that was her
cousin who used to pick her from school
so nobody would [ __ ] with her but could
i say and yeah people and she would just
go watch this i'm going to watch this i
said i said i was sticking my fingers up
my ass yeah well that was you
you're you're a doctor though you could
say
whatever you want it's all about context
you were cleaning yourself she would
throw a chewed gum in all all those
you know gingery white well white boys
hairs and then and then she would go
watch this and it would stick in there
and then like i used to comb in your
hair i used to write graffiti so i used
to have to like draw pictures of her and
she used to want me to draw like
pictures of how she would look naked
getting like banged out and stuff no and
then she wouldn't throw the gum in my
hair yeah but all the rest of it so you
would literally draw porn for her to not
get gum
i would draw she would bully me into
drawing her in graffiti porn to not it
gum throw it into my hair what a wild
story yeah it's true wow that's like
doing nothing that's like it sounds like
from a male 1 middle school yeah like
sixth grade wait but the fact is that
the the viewers the let's just want to
know this is an episode everybody loves
chris
but how did you get into graffiti
um i always would just draw tag stuff
and everything i used to write i used to
write shaz
and then some kid in school saw me
writing him once and he was like what
he saw well he saw me writing drawing a
picture of shackles are you a jack fan
and i wrote shaq and he was like what
that says and i was like he says this is
shaz and i was like [ __ ] yeah it does
and then i became shaz and then all
throughout my i started being jazzed wow
jazz did you ever get caught by the cops
uh i didn't get caught by the cops i got
caught in school in high school i would
write it in the school and then my mom
they're gonna expel me my mom came in
and she
had just graduated college she was you
know later as an art teacher and they
were short our teachers so they offered
her a job as they were trying to kick me
out of school and she politely declined
and they brought me back in school but
she never got qualified
there was one time i was close to
getting caught by the cops i used i was
still aware all black but we were
tagging up stuff you know for this crew
i used to roll with and the cops sounds
like you are like a cat like a big
somebody in the ninja turtles movie
i literally dove into like where the
sewer is and there was a bunch of leaves
and i piled leaves on myself and i
remember covering up my nike symbols
like this yeah and the cops had the
light on me the whole way through and
then just kept rolling
i would love like your kids to be
watching this be like our dad did
graffiti look at him
what did you say they're getting good i
teach them graffiti wow way to go it's
just turning your kids to criminals
and also your mom uh raises crocodiles
right my mom she doesn't know i mean
literally you are puerto rican on paper
racist crocodiles
she was a foster home in louisiana she
lived in jersey city
and then they brought her she she went
to louisiana and foster home and then
she had a crocodile from louisiana and
then she ended up going back to jersey
city and brought the crocodile with her
and it grew big enough that it lived in
the um in the tub
and then they were like well this is too
[ __ ] big we can't do this in the
apartment so they let it outside by the
duncan projects in the park and she said
it was a big hoopla there was a lot to
do police you let a live alligator out
into public i i didn't my mom did yeah
but
because because really that's a
that's that's a liability that's risky
big crime yeah
that crowd could have bowed down like
that was ten human beings nobody cares
people were smacking you know yeah
hitting the face with erasers and [ __ ] i
guess alligators running around maybe
they wouldn't know it came from her but
just she she would never know if the
croc ate like a chihuahua or a child no
it's one of those things you let it go
and then you look away you know
what other things are like that chris j
comedy folks yo this edible just hit me
yeah either level
this i mean
literally it was almost like i was here
i was here and now
it's just it's like this thing that's
going up like the plane's taking off
like the southwest plane has taken off
and we're just
shout out southwest
southwest is the most surprising best
airline a lot of people [ __ ] on it let
me tell you something southwest has
given me the best flying experience i've
had in years i think it's pretty true
like they were seamless
seamless
is a sponsor but united has canceled
flights to me five times in the last
month and yeah you know you pay all this
money for first class united american
airlines nobody [ __ ] that you don't do
the same job southwest southwest wi-fi
is always perfect the flight attendants
are cracking jokes the only thing
southwest has to pick up the pace on is
a lot of times they're scanner breaks
but they just let everybody on the plane
anyway and then everyone has to be
seated and they have to individually
check the ticket to make sure there's
not a stowaway or a terrorist on the
flight that's the only knock on
southwest if they need updated scanners
it's happened on every flight so yeah
everything else really was awesome yeah
and also the people have really good
demeanors great they're cracking jokes
they're all smiles but it feels like
it's coming from a real place it's a
bundle of fun yeah yeah you got a free
drink ticket i got a free ticket and how
about this today when we i was going to
check the luggage uh i gave her my the
southwest agent at the luggage check i
gave her my id i didn't wait for the
same id i give her my id she goes you
listen to the rules baby and then she
gave me a card for 2500 bonus miles at
southwest okay just because i gave the
id and then sal
sees that and says i'm going to one-up
you
i stick my license right to my forehead
she looks the other way she turns back
to me i got my license right here i'm
like i uh what'd she call she said you
you did what you said you did
you followed the rules
you fought somebody follows the rules
like somebody else follows the rules and
she goes i don't have another card she
goes out of cards she took a napkin and
covered up the thing of cards she
charged him double for his bag the [ __ ]
out of here i also this week i found out
about what dark matter is i just wanted
to throw it on your wall
dark matter
is the term astronomers use to describe
material in the universe that does not
emit or reflect light and is therefore
invisible stars nebulae and galaxies are
examples of luminous objects in the sky
the rest of the matter is cold and dark
hidden from people's direct view so
that's interesting because that means
that like dark matter could be like in
this room right now if it's invisible
it's a dark matter
dark matter doesn't it refer to the like
this the part of the stratus the part of
space that it gets dark from like in our
eyes point of view here we go do you see
it as just any negative space well i'll
tell you what cell dark matter is the
most mysterious non-interacting
substance in the universe its
gravitational effects are necessary to
explain the rotation of galaxies the
motions of clusters and the largest
scale structure in the entire universe
you lost me long ago
how about what about for the last very
last episode joker's the last prank when
he gets shot into space would you guys
do it
[Laughter]
we have to go bigger and better you ever
seen that guy felix bomb garner jump
from out of space
sal have you ever seen this no pull up
felix bomb garner red bull jumps from
outer space highest free fall look at
this and then they have 231 you want to
type in brian baumgartner islanders we
can watch some people get beat up let's
do it this is patreon so we're not going
to get [ __ ] for this right or we'll
just look at this watch watch watch this
yeah there's no he's going to mute it
okay look at this he goes up in a hot
air balloon to i mean beyond watch this
he's in a [ __ ] little a little pod he
goes all the way up this guy
part of the free fall he was going to
lose consciousness for that's what he
practiced oh my god so look it's all oh
my god up and up and up is he just a
thrill seeker or is this scientific he's
it was all put on by red bull but my
[ __ ]
it's all red bull
i mean sponsored by red bull to drop in
beings
out of space and you're gonna pass out
look at this sponsored by red bull how
nerve wracking goes when he opens the
pod door but what is this for is this
for red bull promotion oh yeah look at
this wow how nerve-wracking is this look
at look could you imagine and then you
just have to i can't even get into a
cold bath zenith and red bull oh this is
literally the most like they're staying
my [ __ ] is [ __ ] type
this is this is the most bright somebody
get me a washcloth
oh my god and then part of he free-falls
for four minutes two of them he loses
consciousness at
and are you kidding me and would it so
it basically if he doesn't wake up in
the real world conditions yes he's dead
everyone knows that everyone's gonna
watch him die yes exactly john men look
at that guy and then he [ __ ] landed
he landed on his feet from [ __ ] space
what about you ever seen travis pastrana
jump out of the plane without the
parachute and catch the parachute midair
what
put it on pimp travis pastrana
no parachute jumps out of the look at
this
look at this watch this watch this you
want another red ball
red bull's got their hand in the till
the monster energy he's just stepped the
[ __ ] up yes look at this
look at that he looks like chris johnson
oh my god oh my god
billy madison around oh my gosh oh my
god parachute oh my god what the he has
no parachute zero he is one thou look at
how free he is
in his socks watch this he's shirtless
and then in the middle of this his boys
assemble a parachute onto him if at any
moment they would have accidentally
dropped the parachute or something could
have went wrong yeah then he absolutely
would have fallen to his death what what
what is worth doing this for he's calm
he has total trust in that he's count
reverse cowgirl how do red bull get
these people to resilience and has trust
there's a bigger story here look at that
sal doesn't trust that i'm gonna stick
to my time every night
[Laughter]
no but red bull wow
red bull is pushing the limits of
humanity what is something crazier they
could do than this they had somebody
jump out of the stratosphere well i mean
this is an ad read
crazy shoot you when somebody had a son
yeah you survived red bull someone right
into the sun what if better help said
guys you're going to get in a plane
and you're going to jump yeah i couldn't
skydive i mean i i would that would take
red bull money
how much are these people getting
they're like okay you go in the room
they're in the room with red bull execs
the red looks like hear us out
we launch you into outer space
and then we let you go yeah
i mean if those next words out of their
mouth aren't 100 and like 999 million
dollars
well honestly i want to survive that and
then do whatever i want every day till
the day i die what's the number for you
for you to do what felix baumgartner did
and jump from above the stratosphere
what's the number you do that there
could be no number
you would never do it never see that's
the thing what if i gave you a lifetime
lifetime supply candles from the
columbus gamble shop oh you're making it
interesting
[Laughter]
would you do it chris
no ah no no no i don't think i mean you
would have to tell first of all you
would have to tell me that you would
have to assure me have an account that
my kids would be set for life because i
don't i don't think i make it out i feel
like you'd be the guy like you that's
why you would get on the first
commercial flight to the moon and then
you tag it up with shads
you know you looked up at the moon every
night you saw shaz across the world oh
my god you just tagged up a moon rock i
would be the
the sickest graffiti ever to take up the
[ __ ] zone funny i would love it oh my
god i'm never doing that
it'd be weird now because i'm thinking
if you said to me i'll give you 20 i'll
give you a hundred billion dollars 100 i
wouldn't do it
i just i would literally have to think
about the the life that i
what i could have done even
you know the amount of things that could
go wrong you would say
no because it's either that of my life i
still want my life right i mean you
would do it
if you don't survive
that's it then what's the point i would
i would i have a i have you know i'm
okay now and i need a 200 billion but
right but i would i would be very
altruistic with it right
what's the first thing you do what would
you what would a guy like sal volcano do
with a hundred billion dollars bill 100
bill
literally i'd
this this is still greedy but i have to
because only because you asked me for a
judgment immediately i'd probably take
198 billion and immediately donate it to
charities you seriously would yeah yeah
because i'm good with a billion yeah
would you buy a billion dollars of
sneakers
yeah that might be the issue
it
yeah yeah i i don't know right because
what do you need more than a billion
probably even less than that right you
don't even
what i mean women what would you do with
a he gave all the money away that's why
200 billion is the same to me as like
500 million dollars with a hundred
billion i would only ever need 500
million dollars let's see if you gave me
a hundred billion dollars well right off
the bat i'd have to give sixty percent
to uh illegally she'd get about 40 bills
she'd get 40 billion and then uh god
knows what would happen there i think i
buy kanye west that's what i do i buy
kanye and i say you i know
well i can't say that i now own you cut
that part out
you'd write them like a donda yeah yeah
that's sort of that's even worse chris
chess [ __ ] strikes again this episode
is called comet chas
dude shaz versus tt jerry who wins oh my
god this columbus crowd went nuts for tt
tonight they lost
on the women they were [ __ ] went wild
of course they always go that's right
they want bananas for ttv yeah
titi's got to come on hey baby will be
the guest on hey baby tt's going to be
at the beacon theater and borgata and
she's getting off parole march 12th to
14th so she will be coming to my show
march 25th at the win las vegas at the
win i'll be at the win las vegas march
25th t.t jerry is coming to celebrate
her first two weeks of freedom and then
she'll probably go back to prison and
well the whole thing will go to [ __ ] but
what can you do and how about this ready
for this big reveal this is actually
this actually might even be you might be
like wow i gotta come to vegas march
25th i have a show at the win 8 o'clock
i'm going to stay an extra day
because march 26th i was just told
confirmed me the homeless pimp tt jerry
front row tickets with backstage passes
with backstage
front row seats with backstage passes
to
a singer who sings very infrequently who
rarely does concerts anymore who is a
walking legend hall of fame legend adele
folks
and the back stage passes with adele
with skinny adele what are your dishes
what do you think tt's going to say to
adele what is tt gonna say to adele you
covered it though
we did hey babe from the inside
i think
i would say tt the first thing tt would
probably say to adele what was the first
thing
she would probably say um i need to be
there for that moment oh my god i would
love it she'd be like you know what suck
the son of sam's dead
she'll be like you should be oh you lost
weight you look good yeah
wait is this show march 25th or 24th
do you know pimp no i don't know pimp
doesn't know what the [ __ ] going i'm
gonna be
me and pimp are gonna be together for
pimp's birthday february 13th
or pittsburgh one of those two i got
detroit and pittsburgh coming up and
albany and burlington and maybe a third
show at foxwoods and who knows albany
are you doing
just in time to end the show
[Laughter]
scrambled
i [ __ ] love it
egg white power
i'm gonna let you get this one you're
gonna let you get i'ma let you get it
[Music]
[ __ ] nailed it
i um
chris
where else am i gonna be when does this
come out you guys it's tomorrow oh okay
hold on then
this is a patreon baby this these are
i'm going to be in indianapolis i'm
going to be in des moines and i'm going
to be in cleveland next next
january 13 14 15.
i'll be with sal and i also got a really
good gig at a vfw and uh
that's what it is back of a firehouse
yeah man he's gonna [ __ ] start
tagging that mailboxes near you any debt
and tomorrow's new year's show oh
tomorrow's the new year's eve show
tomorrow's new year's eve today is new
year's eve oh yeah yeah
new year's eve we're in cincinnati at
the taft theater uh if you're in the
area come it should be fun we said if it
sells out we will go out with everybody
if it sells out we will go out with
everybody there and when we have rented
out uh a room and a steakhouse that
holds about 15 people
so we're kind of on the fence maybe we
pick maybe we pick five people from the
crowd yeah
just so we know everyone's safe that's
what it is so yeah well not but then you
got to wear three masks for the whole
time n95s and 96 the whole game
everybody baby hot in 97. i
i
um i'm gonna be uh you know what i'm
gonna be baby you know you're the you're
the diehards if you listen if you're a
patreon member and you come to my show
you know the [ __ ] rules you get
kissed right on the lips you identify
yourself i tap kiss you in front of
everybody man woman child whatever it is
i'll [ __ ] kiss everybody if you're on
the patreon
this has been a year of patreon
[ __ ] now we're not even out of here yet
we're at 10 months and you guys girls
and babies
i mean baby i ain't buying lady gaga
t-shirts on a whim if it's not for your
support you supported tt jerry tt
jerry's got a whole new life homeless
pimp's got a whole new wardrobe
you know
i'm trying to get some new cubic
zirconia yeah we call him on the last
day on the last day we introduced you to
[ __ ] to chris johnson i mean look at
that baby who who do you know out there
is doing graffiti rock and double
earrings
i mean that looks like shane what's his
name
sheamus sheamus it's like sheamus damn
sheamus oh dude
yeah and uh
and if you're watching from hey babe uh
patreon is going up soon
patreon is going up soon but you know
what on the hey baby you know what is
the truth is the merch really is going
up soon oh two weeks we started selling
the merch
shows this week shows this week
so yeah baby so it's been good it's been
a blessing um thank you for for giving
me uh a very great year i mean it's been
unbelievable we had our first tv show we
lost it um
we had
we had uh our first house we lost it
and
and uh special we had our first special
we lost it so
we
got not hold on to your wallet uh hold
on to wallet but i had a beautiful you
know beautiful uh life beautiful year
beautiful family um
and so so it's just been great um and
somehow man it's 20 21. tampa tony's
still alive all you guys thought he was
gonna die in 2021 wrong again he lives
to see another year way to go dad
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say